Hey guys, how's it going it's Justine and guess who it is?
It's me!
It's Ro!
I've missed you so much!
I know Justine's been gone in Hawaii, and I missed her terribly I almost flew in for a day
But I remembered I had made promises an engagement so it would have been a lot of fun one night. That's insane
I would have flown to Hawaii, but like I miss you
And then flow now and I was like if I can't it's been one day yeah, that's not worth it
But we will go again. Yeah, but what I have brought for you today
Is something super exciting. You guys know that we absolutely love Starbucks, and coffee and everything that is in that
World of Starbucks. Love. What did you bring me?
Zombie Frappuccinos. Now these have been through
Los Angeles traffic so they may not be at the caliber
Oh, okay, when I first got them
oh, oh, the home has gone down a little bit little whipped cream has deflated a little bit
But I'm seeing a light purple this this is so cool
oh wow it held up Pretty well
Looks like when I picked it up, so that's a good thing this cooler is great
I miss you terribly, but you just brought me the new new this is supposed to look like brains
Like zombie brains. Yeah, do you think so well it's green like you know the cartoon zombies
And then we've got a little bit of like dark red
coming down
So it's kind of like bloody and then I wonder if this was more foamy because it did come from traffic so did definitely
Deflate a little bit like a No did you try the  cotton candy frappicciono  I did try the cotton candy Frappuccino
And I tried the unicorn Frappuccino, but I was a little bit late. It was the unicorn one
Yes, it tasted really sour yeah, it tasted like a sour mango
I wasn't the biggest fan of that
But I think this is gonna be a little bit better house bunch of people I saw cuz I was reading reviews cuz this is
Green, we won't know what the flavor was
But they said it should have been like a matcha tea or something like that makes sense a green tea a matcha
But it's not it's not
Miss the mark green apple. Yeah, I think it is actually a mint, and no we're not meant do you say caramel or caramel?
It's supposed to be caramel, but I say caramel okay. Me too. Well. I'm gonna get rid of this cooler, okay
You can get it on Amazon. I got it for a great deal. There you go
Thank you how to open your straws like I do this its because I used to waitress so we used to break
Just just the tip like this, and then you would remove the bottom and just put the top in
So that you know people could remove it themselves that's a good idea
Please see soup really like a hip hop and see if this looks like a nurse. You're really dig in and just whoa
Just start carrying. Oh Chuck. Oh, is it a red velvet. I don't know
Oh, is it an apple on the bottom red velvet on the top. What are you is it freezing whipped cream?
Purple
No taste like anything the color makes me think it should taste like berries
Yeah, that's like blackberry raspberries, but I'm not mad, and I'm just you know disappointed
What do any other thing that my mom was Adin? What do we do next not mad just?
Don't know what to do because right when the unicorn Frappuccino came out
I felt like I was the last person to try it yeah, but now I feel like I'm trying this right away
Okay, let's just try it right
It's really sweet oh
This is so weird it's like I think I definitely taste the chocolate the aftertaste
I was gonna say is cocoa I'm tasting an aftertaste of cocoa it's like green apple hits me, and I could be totally wrong
It's like a sweet sweet something we need a sweet Apple, and then the aftertaste is cocoa super sweet apple and chocolate apples
Apple Crunch, there's no crunch there should be Y does not even Apple at all
Maybe it's pear and I can't tell oh oh that tastes like Apple mm
OH maybe caramel apple with a little bit of chocolate yeah, that sounds good that sounds
delicious
That's what it is my vote is a caramel apple with a little bit of chocolate aftertaste YUM like whatever
This is how to taste the barrier
maybe that's just I'm getting confused by the Apple the color is tripping me out because your color this looks like it should be a
Blackberry hmm hmm
You haven't give my drink Cola, so I'm gonna get a tummy ache
Oh, but I think it might be worth it is there anything hidden in here hmm
Look at me. Let me feel around
Okay, I definitely finger know there's jumps in there
Yeah, I probably
Like body parts, maybe like a problem bleeding. I'm so cool. I'd be really creepy Wow
Really creep people out put an eyeball in there
Happy Halloween
I've got me what I really really freak people out
I just protein probably I feel like that's a delicacy somewhere, so I would say like on a scale of one to ten
What would you give this scale one to ten also be kind of like a scale of like something you wouldn't obviously have everyday
But just like a yeah probably not everyday cuz I have my favorite go to Starbucks drinks cuz I'm really particular
I grew up in Seattle home of Starbucks the heart of Starbucks, so I definitely have my favorites
I would say that this is pretty neat if you like a green apple flavor
It's a lot of my watch. I'm gonna hit. Oh. No. I got I got Hey
Hello, got whipped cream all over my watch oh
Wait, did you give it a rating? It was like oh, I forgot okay? How do we do it, right?
Let me get it right and you maybe you do a rating first cuz I'm not really good as Rayleigh
I'm not either, but I would say I would give it a 7, but now
This is a scale of 10 so the only reason I'm giving it a lower score is because it doesn't have coffee, and I love
Caffeinated beverages this doesn't have coffee. Oh, I'm feeling a lot of energy, so it must be from sugar
That's it and I would say the unicorn frappe because I didn't really like it was probably a four so just one
Way higher, I would say it's not my favorite Starbucks drink in the whole world
But a really neat idea definitely like this but Starbucks. I'm waiting for the 10
Where's the spresso shocked I mean? I just drink basic black coffee, so I'm really
Just a little this is neat. I love it cheers Cheers
Mmm no.2 at Starbucks. Oh well my cold is there coffee Frappuccino light. I love that so good however
I'm feeling if it's a really hot day like it has been here has been like a hundred and 310 degrees
I'll just do an iced coffee with a little bit of almond milk sometimes a little bit of coconut milk
And then if it's a hot drink. Oh, chai tea latte, or a vanilla soy latte
I'm in now. Do you like the Oprah? Chai is it? Cuz that's a lot of chai?
It's a lot of time you like that. I always say extra Oprah, and they're like, huh?
That means extra. Chai, yes, see I like just their regular try, but you like try a lot do I love it
Well, I mean I guess that's it. There's really not much more. We could say about this. Yeah well
I'm just glad I got to try the zombie
Frappuccino got to try the new new while it's new well guys. Thanks for watching make sure you check out Rose Channel
We've done so many Starbucks videos, so I'll also put links to those cuz they were super fun
We did last year we did the pumpkin and that was a bad the fall trip all drinks. I'm so great well
That's it see you later. Bye